see how traffic's moving along well we
have traffic that's turned into a police
investigation Northbound I-15 from the
215 is a parking lot if you can avoid
the north 15 maybe on the North 15 get
off at the 215 and go either East or
West depending on where you're trying to
go because this is going to be there for
a while because it's already been there
for more than three hours this is the
northbound 15 at springmont you might
recognize the exits there to Spring
Mountain and Caesars Palace just off
screen there to your right so the two
right lanes have been taken up since 3
30 this morning I believe this started
out as a crash but unconfirmed reports
are indicating that there may be some
kind of an investigation possibly
involving a shooting that may have taken
place somewhere else bottom line for you
Northbound on the 15. you're backed up
to the 215. you might want to change
your travel plans now there are some
Lanes getting through there so it's not
as big a deal as it could be